[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire rien de plus culturelle que
notre façon de nous nourrir c'est
pourquoi ces différents en fonction des
époques des milieux et de la géographie
aujourd'hui je reçois l'historien
florent quellier pour son histoire de
l'alimentation de la préhistoire à nos
jours qui vient de paraître chez belin
c'est la première histoire globale de
l'alimentation dans toutes ses
composantes
un gros livre illustré de 800 pages
rédigé par les meilleurs spécialistes
mais d'abord une image celle que vous
avez choisie pour illustrer ce début de
xxième siècle cette image là voici
pourquoi
pourquoi celle-ci c'est une photo qui
avait fait la une de ouest france le 3
avril 2020 donc il ya quasiment un an
jour pour jour et c'est une image qui
m'avait marqué par l'intensité du regard
de la grand mère c'est un échange entre
un petit fils et une grand mère dans une
maison hospitalisés en banlieue de
rennes et on voit tout l'amour de cette
grand mère son geste son regard ses
mains posées sur la vitre et elle a
oublié le photographe visiblement alors
que le le psychisme est un peu plus gêné
un petit peu gauche comme peut l'être
parfois un adolescent qui est peut-être
plus gêné par cette preuve d'amour en
public devant le le photographe et moi
ce que j'ai surtout aimé dans cette
photo c'est la solidarité entre ces deux
générations
actuellement il ya un discours un peu
victimaire sur l'idée qu'on aurait
sacrifié la jeunesse pour les personnes
âgées
là on a un autre discours qui me semble
beaucoup plus positive dans le cadre de
la crise que nous vivons de cette
relation de ces échanges et surtout
c'est une très belle image de l'humanité
ce qu'on aimerait voir plus souvent
c'est à dire l'amour gratuit tout
simplement et bien commençons
[Musique]
florent quellier vous êtes professeur
d'histoire moderne à l'université
d'angers vous êtes l'un des grands
spécialistes de l'histoire de
l'alimentation
et c'est sous votre direction que vient
de paraître chez belin cette première
histoire globale de l'alimentation de la
préhistoire à nos jours
gros gros livre un qui commence par
cette réflexion il n'y a rien de plus
triviale que manger et en même temps
rien de plus complexe c'est à savoir un
apprentissage donc une culture qui
dépend étroitement de l'époque du lieu
et du milieu dans lequel envie c'est une
part capitale de la tri d'entités au
fond à tel point que si on nous servait
aujourd'hui ce dont se régaler nos
ancêtres sous l'ancien régime ou au
moyen-âge
nous serions probablement incapables
d'apprécier très probablement parce que
notre palais est éduqué on a un palais
qu'éduquer pour apprécier des mets du
21e siècle
et donc quand bien même on pourrait
faire à l'identique les recettes des
temps passés ce qui est totalement
impossible on n'arriverait pas à les
apprécier
en revanche ce que l'on peut apprécier
c'est l'imaginaire ce sont les cultures
associées à cette alimentation puisque
dans cette longue histoire qui est une
histoire de l'humanité le culturel et
centrale nous mangeons enfin moi je
mange des cuisses de grenouilles
mais je ne mange pas de chien voilà tout
ça c'est en fait le hasard qui veut qui
sait déterminés par le hasard qui m'a
fait naître à un endroit à une époque
exactement c'est déterminé par une
culture par un apprentissage
le nouveau-né très rapidement apprend
les premières règles de vie en commun
notamment autour de l'alimentation et en
fonction du milieu social en fonction de
votre religion ou d'absence de religion
vous avez des goûts et dégoûts alors le
disco diététique occidentale
d'aujourd'hui qui conquit qui condamne
au fond l'alimentation trop grasse
d'alimentation trop sucrés
l'alimentation trop carnet est ce que ça
a déjà existé
précédemment à d'autres époques en
d'autres lieux oui il ya eu tout à
partir de l'époque antique a pas tort de
l'antiquité a par moments on a des
sources là on peut travailler
sur un discours médical sur un discours
diététique et en fonction des
civilisations vous avez des
prescriptions qui peuvent être très
différentes par exemple pour l'époque
médiévale on est très hostile aux crues
le cru est considéré comme dangereux
parce que la digestion est comprise
comme une cuisson et donc si vous mangez
des aliments crus
vous allez fatigué votre organisme qui
de va qui va devoir cuir intégralement
le produit alors que si le produit est
déjà cuits et associés à des épices qui
sont chaudes
ça va faciliter la digestion donc dans
la société d'ancien régime un médecin ne
vous aurais jamais dit mangez cinq
fruits et légumes par jour parce que les
fruits sont aussi considérés comme
dangereux et si vous voulez manger cru
là c'est d'autant plus dangereux et ça
c'est un discours qui évidemment a
totalement changé au xxème siècle vous
je peux vous donner un autre exemple
avec par exemple les légumineuses
aujourd'hui on a un discours des
thématiques qui va valoriser les
légumineuses en soulignant que c'est une
source de protéines de protéines
végétales et que cela peut être une
façon de manger - moins de viande
si vous prenez l'époque moderne l'ancien
régime
les légumineuses sont considérés comme
des légumes grossier très dur a dit à
digérer et qui en plus a on le problème
de créer des flatulences et donc ça
créerait un problème de contrôle de son
corps et l'obsession de manger sainement
c'est propre à notre époque où à toutes
les époques là aussi on a voulu manger
sainement
en fait c'est propre à toutes les
époques l'on peu documenté puisque ça
renvoie à un savoir un savoir diététique
donc c'est absolument pas à l'époque
contemporaine qui crée cette idée de
manger sainement
en revanche ce qui est très différent
c'est que on n'a pas la même définition
de ce qui est sain au 21e que dans les
époques plus anciennes par exemple dans
les ehpad plus ancien le gras est
survalorisé on est dans une société
lipophiles sur la très très longue durée
c'est-à-dire dès la préhistoire
dès qu'on peut vraiment travailler sur
des régimes alimentaires
on s'aperçoit que
les hommes ont recherché la grèce la
grèce d'origine animale et c'est un
élément qui va vraiment courir toute
l'époque médiévale et l'ancien régime
le gras est vraiment associé au désir
est associée à la richesse à la réussite
et à partir du 19ème et surtout du 20e
on va avoir un discours qu'il a commencé
cette fois a critiqué l' usage du gras
et qui va développer un discours qui est
plutôt l'ipo fob et qu'on va retrouver
aujourd'hui et je peux vous donner un
dernier exemple sur un changement
concernant un une nourriture qui a été
encensé par les médecins et qui
aujourd'hui est très critiqué le sucre
le sucre lorsque le sucre arrive en
occident allez les premiers contacts
avec le sucre c'est le 10ème siècle au
cours du moyen âge le sucre elle dans
les épices et relève du monde de la
pharmacopée inde et des médicaments et
le sucre est considéré comme facilitant
la digestion et est utilisée dans la
médecine pour enrober par exemple les
pilules amères parce qu'il va donner
après le terme de bonbons par exemple et
ce n'est qu'à partir du xviie siècle
dans le monde anglo saxon qu'on commence
à avoir des médecins qui vont condamner
l'usagé du sucre en disant que le sucre
est dangereux pour la santé peu noircir
les dents peut provoquer un certain
nombre de maladies
mais pendant une grande partie de son
histoire le sucre a été paré de très
très nombreuses vertus
vous avez eu main un célèbre proverbe de
la renaissance
on trouve aussi bien en france que qu'en
italie qui ait jamais sucre ne gâte à
viande jamais sucre ne gâte à viande
viande veut dire aliments et cela veut
dire que n'ayez pas peur de mettre du
sucre sur les aliments que vous allez
manger ça ne peut être que bon pro de
santé et et le fait que quand on est
très angoissé aujourd'hui à l'idée que
l'alimentation puisse nous rendre malade
ça ça existait donc déjà au moyen-âge ou
sous l'ancien régime
or au moyen-âge et sous l'ancien régime
vous avez deux peur autour de
l'alimentation
vous avez une peur liée à
l'approvisionnement
le problème de l'approvisionnement sur
le temps long une histoire
d'alimentation c'est essentiellement le
problème de l'approvisionnement de l'e10
est des famines manger à sa faim
un qui est un élément essentiel pour les
peurs alimentaires mais vous avez
également des questions qualitative
manger un aliment qui serait contraire à
votre tempérament qui serait
incompatible avec ce que vous êtes
parce que dans l'alimentation vous avez
quelque chose de très intime en réalité
il ya probablement pas grand chose de
plus intime que le fai alimentaire dans
le sens où vous acceptez d'incorporer un
corps étranger vous acceptez
d'incorporer un corps qui va faire corps
qui va faire votre cher d'où les peurs
pour certains aliments qui sont
considérés comme ignoble ou du monde
dans certaines cultures et donc la peur
de se contaminer avec certains certains
aliments d'où les doux les alors là on
l'a déjà et d'où les alimentation
particulière
le végétarisme le véganisme le sans
gluten quand on lit votre livre on
comprend bien que au fond la france a
toujours été très intolérante avec ça
avec les alimentation particulière
beaucoup plus que les anglo saxons par
exemple à quoi ça tient
alors effectivement le rapport
alimentation particulière n'est à sion
pas identiques entre l'europe latine il
n'y a pas que la france mais l'europe
latine de de culture catholique et le
monde anglo saxon de culture protestante
voir puritaine dans le monde anglo saxon
les alimentations particulières sont
liées à la liberté de l'individu c'est
un droit de l'individu
l'individu peut être végétarien peut
être vegan peut avoir vraiment son
propre régime du côté français on est
dans une culture de l'alimentation qui
est largement marquée par le
christianisme et surtout pas
le catholicisme et c'est une culture qui
est associé à la communion de la table à
la convivialité au fait qu'on doit
manger ensemble les mêmes plats que l'on
doit partager et donc du côté français
les alimentation particulière sonne un
petit peu comme une déviance comme un
caprice déjà sur l'expression
alimentation particulière qui sonne
d'une manière négative un petit peu
comme naguère on parlait des amitiés
particulières il ya cette déviance est
sanction de la société et 7 aliments
qu'on va retrouver également dans la
manière de parler des aliments sans le
sang est privatif sans gluten sans gras
et c est au contraire du côté anglo
saxons on va utiliser des expressions
comme gluten free est donc avec fluide
on va mettre en avant l'idée de liberté
donc même la langue montre qu'on n'a pas
ce même rapport
cette même tolérance et du côté français
la peur c'est vraiment de rompre la
communion de table les changes de
pouvoir manger ensemble les mêmes plats
et danser alimentation particulière y en
a une comme le véganisme par exemple qui
relève du militantisme est ce qu'il ya
eu d'autres façons de s'alimenter dans
l'histoire dans le but de changer le
monde
parce que c'est ce que veulent les vegan
il voudrait changer le monde en
s'alimentant de la manière dont ils
s'alimentent est-ce que c'est déjà
arrivé ça ou est ce que c'est une forme
de militantisme totalement nouvelle
alors sur la dimension militante oui
c'est quand même nouveau c'est vraiment
une originalité de second xxème et
xxième siècle en revanche dans le temps
long de l'histoire on retrouve des
prescriptions alimentaires qui ont comme
objectif de modifier l'homme ou de
dominer l'animalité qui est dans l'homme
c'est un élément que l'on peut voir par
exemple dans
le christianisme avec l'alternance entre
les jours maigres et les jours gras dire
que dans le christianisme il n'y a pas
de tabous alimentaires absolue il n'y a
pas un interdit pour qu'ils seraient
absolue en revanche vous avez une
succession d'interdît calendaire où vous
n'avez pas le droit de manger de la
viande et l'idée est de modifier son
corps l'idée c'est de dompter c'est
passion et d'essayer de contrôler son
corps donc cette idée d'un contrôle par
l'alimentation
ça oui c'est quelque chose que l'on a pu
voir dans la profondeur historique mais
c'est pas apprend pas à proprement
parler un militantisme en est alors
aujourd'hui on est en pleine
mondialisation alimentaire il suffit
d'aller dans un hypermarché on voit
qu'il ya de la nourriture provenant
absolument tous les pays des nouveaux
des des aliments que nous gardons nos
grands-parents ne soupçonnait même pas
l'existence 56 vous avais quand il avait
20 ans de même dans une grande ville
vous avez des restaurants de toutes
origines je crois qu'en france en tout
cas à paris doit y avoir plus de
restaurants vietnamiens que de pharmacie
c'est rentrer complètement dans notre
vie quotidienne
est ce que c'est la première fois l'idée
de la mondialisation alimentaire j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait ça revient en
permanence quand on lit votre livre on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya déjà une forme de
mondialisation alimentaire après les
grandes découvertes par exemple on a
effectivement plusieurs mondialisation
alimentaire dans la grande différence
c'est que aujourd'hui on a conscience
qu'on mange exotiques ou en tout cas on
veut manger exotiques c'est à dire que
dans la mobilisation qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui il ya cette volonté de
manger lier de goûter vraiment lier ce
qui n'était pas le cas dans les autres
périodes historiques mais en revanche
l'histoire de l'humanité autour de
l'alimentation c'est avant tout une
histoire de circulation de plantes
d'animaux et ça dès la préhistoire dès
l'invention de l'agriculture au
néolithique
dix millénaires avant notre ère quand
même il ya déjà ce mouvement est donc on
est dans des processus de circulation
qui peuvent renvoyer à une
mondialisation mais le moment où
réellement dans l'histoire on les élit
devons avoir conscience que il ya une
ouverture du monde
un élargissement du monde c'est avec les
grandes découvertes à partir de la fin
du xvème siècle et la mise en relation
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité de quatre continents l'europe
l'asie et l'afrique était déjà en
contact dès la préhistoire ont été et le
continent américain ainsi qu'une myriade
d'îles et surtout vous allez avoir de
très nombreux aliments qui vont arriver
en europe mais vous aviez d'autres
aliments qui arrivait au cours de
l'époque médiévale et qui était
également étrangers qui venaient de lier
l'aubergine qui était d'origine
asiatique ou l'épinard qui était
d'origine asiatique et ça ça arrive au
cours de l'époque médiévale
là la grande différence c'est qu'avec la
découverte d'un nouveau monde
on a une quantité importante d'aliments
qui sont découverts et qui vont arriver
relativement rapidement en europe
donc ça peut être la pomme de terre la
patate douce le maïs le piment le le
maïs la dinde si on s'intéresse aux
animaux et dans cette première
mondialisation vous allez avoir des
aliments qui vont passer d'un continent
à un autre
dire que les européens vont introduire
des plantes américaine en afrique et en
asie la patate douce par exemple vient
d'amérique et on va la retrouver
jusqu'au japon au xviie siècle par les
européens les européens vont introduire
en amérique des plantes d'origine
asiatique ont le plus bel exemple qu'on
puisse donner c'est la canne à sucre
même s'il était déjà implantée en
méditerranée à l'époque médiévale
c'est une plante d'origine asiatique
mais ça peut être le cas par exemple
également du tarot un tubercule qui va
être introduit également en amérique au
xviie siècle les européens vont
également diffusé à l'intérieur du monde
amiri
des plantes américaine qui parce que
avant l'arrivée des européens le monde
pré colombien était plutôt cloisonné
donc ce sont par exemple les européens
qui vont introduire la pomme de terre en
amérique du nord où la patate douce en
amérique du nord et les européens vont
également introduire en aux amériques
des plantes et des animaux européen pour
l'approvisionnement des des créoles et
dans cette mondialisation on va avoir un
enrichissement de l'alimentation
occidentale mais qui n'est absolument
pas perçue comme une ouverture aux
saveurs de lier c'est à dire que si vous
prenez par exemple les haricots les
haricots sont d'origine américaine n'y a
pas de haricots pour l'antiquité ou le
moyen-âge en occident on a des fois on a
défait et d'olic
on a l'équivalent des légumes de garde
mais on n'a pas ce que nous appelons
aujourd'hui les ricoh c'est une plante
qui va s'imposer très très rapidement en
europe parce que on sait la cultiver
parce que c'est un légume de garde et
parce qu'on sait la cuisine et donc si
vous prenez par exemple un cassoulet qui
peut paraître être un repas typiquement
européen typiquement français même le le
cassoulet rizet avec une plante qui est
d'origine américaine
mais on a totalement oublié qu'elle
était d'origine américaine et sera même
chose pour le maïs pour la tomate etc
qui sont des plantes qui vont
s'acclimater en plus ou moins rapidement
ça ça dépend des plantes et ça dépend
également si on est capable d'avoir une
analogie avec une plante qui existait en
europe
c'est dire que si on peut faire un
élément de comparaison l'acclimatation
se faire relativement rapidement si vous
prenez par exemple le maïs le maïs les
européens comprennent que c'est une
céréale la culture européenne repose sur
la consommation de céréales alors la
céréale noble c'est le froment mais il y
a des petits grains qui sont réservées
plutôt aux classes populaires
le mil le milieu est le sorgho et c est
le maïs va remplacer le mil le mille
dans les cultures européennes au 16e 17e
et sous préfets par exemple la polenta à
la polenta qui existe déjà à la fin du
moyen-âge pour la vénétie polenta était
grise a été fait à partir de miley elle
devient à la fin au tout début du xviie
elle devient jaune parce que à les
réaliser avec du maïs mais on a cuisiné
le maïs selon les méthodes européenne
donc ça ne pose pas de problème et je
vous donnais un dernier petit exemple
qui est la belle réussite
d'acclimatation d'un animal venant
d'amérique
en fait le seul animal qui va réellement
être intégrés dans les cultures
alimentaires européennes c'est la dinde
un la dinde à les repérer par christophe
colomb lors de ses voyages il parle
d'une grosse poule donc analogie avec la
basse cour européenne et la dinde play
en fait parce que c'est une grosse
volaille et la dinde arrive dans un
système gastronomique qui survalorise la
viande blanche considère que la viande
de volaille et la viande la plus saine
la volaille et tant l'animal le plus
prestigieux dans cette chaîne
alimentaire et on recherche encore des
animaux de grande taille pour les
banquets aristocratique par exemple les
signes par exemple et pan par exemple
les spatules des oiseaux vraiment de
très très content taille et la dinde
elle n'a pas à rougir c'est l'animal
aussi de grande taille et on va là la
comparer aux plans et aux coques donc à
le paon ou une volaille prestigieuse
lecoq donc ça envoie la basse-cour tout
le chapon et c'est largement consommée
et on sait que la dinde est présent dès
le début du xvième siècle en espagne et
en italie en france dans les années 15
130 s'est documenté on sait que
l'aristocratie française mange des
dindes et dans la seconde moitié du
xvième dans les livres de cuisine
imprimer en europe on a des recettes de
dinde
mais ce ne sont pas des recettes
nouvelles en réalité sont des recettes
qui reprennent les recettes de volaille
rôtie mais on a simplement remplacé
cette volaille par la dinde et dans les
années 16 165 70 la dinde arrivent même
à exclure des banquets les autres
volatiles de grande dimension qui
étaient là à là
du moyen-âge et qui vont être remplacé
par la dinde donc c'est une belle
success story à la dinde elle fait
imposé très facilement
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment dans un
pays comme la france que ou nord au sud
est à peu près dans dans toutes les
classes sociales on mange grosso modo la
même chose notre alimentation est
devenue la même mais mais c'est très
récent en fait un les disparités
géographiques sociales
je parle des disparités alimentaire bien
entendu était encore très grande il ya
ne serait-ce que trente quarante
cinquante ans exactement il y avait une
grande diversité géographique et social
un géographiques et sociales avec quand
même des éléments qui était commun par
exemple l'importance des céréales la
france appartient à cette aire de
civilisation du froment et les céréales
étaient consommés en fonction des
régions vous trouviez soit sous forme de
bouillie soit sous forme de galette soit
sous forme de pain de pain plus ou moins
levé la crêpe et la galette n'était
absolument pas une originalité bretonne
sous l'ancien régime ou encore aux au
xixème siècle c'est quelque chose de
largement plus répandue dont vous vous
aviez également le prestige de la viande
important cette société quand bien même
on ne pouvait pas en consommer tous les
jours
l'importance de la soupe de la soupe de
légumes qu'ils étaient également un
élément essentiel est associé aux
céréales mais on consommait en grande
partie ce qu'on arrivait à produire
localement d'où l'importance du naturel
des terroirs pour reprendre l'expression
des géographes ce qu'on arrive
réellement à produire seules les élites
pouvait ne pas se soucier de
l'approvisionnement des contraintes de
l'approvisionnement et avoir une
alimentation autres et une alimentation
qui était probablement plus cosmopolite
si vous prenez par exemple
l'alimentation des élites pour la fin du
moyen âge et la renaissance pour les
élites européennes
en fait on a un style international on a
une cuisine qui est relativement proche
en catalogne en italie
en allemagne en angleterre ou en france
pour les élites avec l'importance des
épices l'importance de la viande etc ce
qui est pas le cas pour la paysannerie
et ce n'est que à l'époque contemporaine
quand on va voir une amélioration des
transports et donc une circulation plus
facile des denrées alimentaires
quand vous avez aussi les progrès de la
les transports qui vont utiliser la
réfrigération et donc ils vont permettre
également à un développement et une
circulation plus rapide de denrées qui
avant étaient des denrées qui était trop
périssables pour circuler qu'on va
commencer à avoir une des modifications
et d'avoir quelque chose de plus
standardisés mais c'est vraiment une
évolution très récente et un film comme
la cuisine au beurre avec bourvil et
fernandel bourvil venant de normandie
faisant de la cuisine au beurre et
fernandel originaire de marseille
faisant de la cuisine à l'huile c'est un
film qui doit datait de 1960 début des
années 60
aujourd'hui ça n'a plus de sens mais
dans 1966 en avait encore alors ça a un
sens parce que dans les années 1960 ça
renvoie aux identités régionales
en fait l'opposition entre la cuisine au
beurre et la cuisine à l'huile donc
huile d'olive ici c'est ça renvoie à la
construction des cuisines régionales
c'est une construction du 19e siècle
avant parle pas de cuisine régionale
avant le 19e siècle
parce que pour qu'il y ait une cuisine
régionale il faut qu'il y ait des
denrées qui circulent et qui soit
reconnu à l'extérieur comme étant
réellement associé à une région et dans
le cadre français qui est un pays très
centralisé
il faut que cette reconnaissance soit
parisienne et au cours du 19e vous avez
le développement de cuisine régionale
dans un premier temps pour des raisons
qui sont à la fois scientifique et
politique c'est à dire vous avez le
mouvement folklorique mais au sens
positif du terme au sens du 19e c'est à
dire une recherche vraiment des cultures
populaires où là on va essayer de
trouver des recettes dites régionales
locales et vous avez également une
approche politique au 19e qui est liée
aux mouvements plutôt régionalistes ou
on veut défendre une identité locale
face à l'état centralisateur et ces deux
éléments vont en fait poussé en quelque
sorte les cuisines régionales et c'est
au 19ème qu'on commence à voir en france
la publication de livres de cuisine qui
sont réellement des livres de cuisine
régionale alors que sous l'ancien régime
on n'a pas de livres de cuisine
régionale et au 19e
on va ajouter le tourisme le tourisme va
jouer un rôle essentiel dans l'invention
des cuisines régionales et la diffusion
des cuisines régionales et la soif du du
patrimoine la volonté d'avoir un
patrimoine
si vous prenez par exemple les guides
touristiques si vous prenez le plus
célèbre dans le guide michelin dans le
guide michelin vous avez les endroits où
il faut s'arrêter est ce qu'il faut voir
dans ces endroits
ces endroits donc vous avez un panorama
elle est vue avoir sur le paysage
vous avez le lieu de culture a visité le
musée où l'homme célèbre qui est né dans
telle ville etc
mais vous avez également la bonne table
la bonne table à laquelle il faut
s'arrêter et les spécialités qu'il faut
goûter et donc ça va habitués les
français progressivement à cette volonté
aussi d'apprécier dans le cadre du
développement du tourisme les
spécialités locales toutes régions
devant avoir des spécialités locales et
dans l'invention de la normandie au sens
de l'invention d'un espace touristique
par les parisiens au 19e vous avez aussi
l'invention de spécialités culinaires
qui sont affrontés à paris et qui vont
être servis après sur la côte aux
parisiens en leur faisant croire que
cette spécialité normande alors vous
avez par exemple l'exemple de la saule à
la normande inquiet une un produit qui
est présenté comme typiquement une
recette qui est présenté comme
typiquement normande
parce que vous avez un produit
identitaire de la normandie legras la
crème la crème qui est présente ici et
le poisson le poisson qui renvoie à la
manche et donc à tout un imaginaire
associé à une spécialité régionale et
dans les années 50-60 vous avez
développement du tourisme en france et
ça a joué un rôle important pour
diffuser ses cuisines régionales et ses
oppositions entre une france du beurre
et une france de l'huile d'olive et
derrière il ya vraiment des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux de marketing mais ce
sont des cuisines qui sont souvent trop
grasse trop riche pour être des cuisines
ancien parce que dans le temps long on
est plutôt dans des sociétés de pénuries
et les recettes dites authentique où les
spécialités présenté comme régionales
qui sont marquées par beaucoup de gras
beaucoup de crème ou beaucoup d'huile
d'olive ou beaucoup de viande ce sont
des cuisines qui sont bien trop riche
pour être en fait le reflet de recettes
quotidiennes
elles sont au mieux des recettes des
jours de noces des jours de fêtes ou au
pire une création marketing pour
profiter du tourisme ont fait une pause
on se retrouve juste après florent
quellier
[Musique]
nous sommes avec l'historien florent
quellier à qui l'on doit le cette
formidable histoire de l'alimentation de
la préhistoire à nos jours très gros
livre qui a été rédigé par tous les
spécialistes de toutes les époques sous
votre direction toutes les illustrations
d'ailleurs qu'on voit défiler derrière
moi sont tirées de ce livre enfin
quellier grignoter en france a toujours
été mal vu pourquoi le grignotage
effectivement est mal vu parce que ça
renvoie un dérèglement du ventre en
réalité pour comprendre cette
condamnation du grignotage
il faut se replacer dans les premiers
temps du christianisme et un discours
qui peut être culpabilisé plus que les
culpabiliser ateurs sur le plaisir
gourmand sur le plaisir de
l'alimentation éléments qui n'existe pas
dans les sociétés antiques avant le
christianisme et le christianisme va
codifier les péchés capitaux utilisé par
le diable pour empêcher l'élévation
notre âme verdure et dans la
codification des péchés capitaux vous
avez un lien qui va être fait entre la
gourmandise et la luxure 1 les deux
étant lire et ça renvoie également au
péché capital au premier péché originel
1 le premier péché qui n'est pas après
on en parle est un péché de gourmandise
mais hulk qui va signifier ce péché de
désobéissance et d'avoir croqué le fruit
défendu et donc ça permet pour l'église
catholique de condamner la gourmandise
en tant que pêcher sauf que il ya l'idée
que le fait de ressentir du plaisir a
été voulue par dieu que dieu a rendu
possible aux hommes d'apprécier la
nourriture afin de pouvoir répondre à
une injonction biblique majeur qui est
croissez et multipliez c'est-à-dire
vivait et
des enfants donc on retrouve la
sexualité et on retrouve l'alimentation
et donc pour l'église
ils ne pouvaient pas directement
condamné le plaisir alimentaire il
fallait arriver à le contrôler et la
manière la réponse qui a été trouvé
c'est de circonscrire le plaisir
alimentaire uniquement à l'heure des
repas
au moment où on peut manger et donc il
va y avoir toute une discipline du corps
qui existent encore en occident qui fait
que l'on mange non pas parce qu'on a
faim mais parce qu'il est l'heure de
manger
ainsi vous prenez 12h30 13h on a une
idée à peu près de ce que font les
français à ce moment là mais savoir ce
qu'ils ont forcément fin c'est que dans
leur culture c'est à ce moment là que
l'on doit manger et ça c'est un
enseignement de l'église c'est un
enseignement de l'église et
l'alimentation est réservée uniquement
aux repas à la table et parallèlement on
va également imposé de bonnes manières
de table des bonnes manières de tata
dire se comporter correctement face aux
autres convives afin de rendre honnête
acceptable le plaisir de manger et
d'échangés l'idée c'est vraiment de
montrer que on n'est pas un animal que
on ne relève pas de la bestialité mais
que l'homme a été fait à l'image de dieu
et donc qui doit se contrôler or
grignoter entre les repas
ça veut dire qu'on est l'esclave de son
ventre ça veut dire qu'on est à l écoute
de son ventre et donc ça veut dire qu'on
se rapproche de l'animalité et que l'on
va connaître un certain nombre de
dérèglements qui marque à la fois
l'alimentation et la sexualité donc des
péchés graves pour l'église
on pourrait dire que dans une société
industrielle ultra développé et
capitaliste comme la société américaine
on va contrôler encore plus
l'alimentation au fond en standardisant
l'alimentation en en faisant quelque
chose de purement industriel sans goût
auquel on va ajouter des condiments
comme le ketchup
mais au fond on a l'impression qu'on
veut réduire le temps du repas au strict
minimum
dans un pays comme les états unis et
cela dès le 19ème siècle à gobrait oui
avec une évacuation de la notion de
plaisir
évacuation totale de la notion de
plaisir de la convivialité
du temps passé à table avec l'idée qu'il
faut rationaliser le temps contrôler le
temps comme on contrôle le temps à l'
usine si on sur les chaînes également
réduire au maximum le temps qui est
obligatoire pour la prise alimentaire
d'ailleurs on va parler de prise
alimentaire et là il ya une rupture
totale avec la vieille europe où on
n'est pas du tout sur cette approche-là
concernant l'alimentation où on est
davantage sur l'idée de prendre
davantage de temps et de se poser et
d'ailleurs on le voit très bien si on
prend lusage des chaînes de fêtes de
fast food en stase unis et en europe
en europe on a tendance en europe
continentale a utilisé les fast food
comme un endroit où on peut se poser où
on peut s'arrêter manger échanger
discuter
on n'est plus dans la logique du fast
food à proprement parler contrairement à
ce qu'on peut voir en amérique du nord
ou à londres par exemple et là on voit
bien que c'est une rupture culturelle
entre deux approches très différentes de
l'alimentation et on voit également une
des raisons qui peut expliquer le succès
de la mondialisation la mondialisation
donc si on regarde l'exemple du fast
food et du hamburger il ya évidemment un
imaginaire qui est un imaginaire qui
renvoie aux états unis on ne peut pas
dire le contraire mais en même temps
c'est un imaginaire qui est dans un lieu
adapté à une culture préexistantes et la
réussite de la mondialisation
ce n'est pas en fait la même nourriture
qui est servi par tous sur l'ensemble de
la planète
c'est une nourriture qui est adapté aux
goûts et aux attentes de la population
même les hamburgers ne sont pas les
mêmes aux etats-unis ou en asie
je prenais pas dans la pizza la pizza
qu'on va retrouver un peu partout dans
le monde occidental dans le cadre
français un plus vous allez vers le nord
est le plus la pizza est épaisse plus on
va trouver des pizzas de la crème
fraîche et donc on va aller vers une
autre approche de ce qu'est la pizza
compte par rapport à l'italie et là on a
un très très bel exemple des raisons de
du succès d'une mondialisation qui est
vraiment une adaptation aux
des consommateurs mais qui garde un
imaginaire commun véhiculée par une pop
culture en fait par les médias par les
films par la littérature les bandes
dessinées etc et être gros aujourd'hui
c'est très belle vue est-ce que ça a
toujours été le cas
non il ya aussi une histoire de la
corpulence la la corpulence pour
l'époque médiévale et l'ancien régime
est plutôt un signe de bonne santé
bonne santé morale bonne santé
économique et la notion d'embonpoint est
une notion positive
il faudrait écrire en bon point en trois
mots en fait en bons points ce qui veut
dire au juste milieu entre le maigre et
le gras le maigre est mal vu le maigre
est associé à la pauvreté est associée à
la maladie est associé à une ambition
qui va vous rongez 1 pensez par exemple
à l'image du jésuite ambitieux qui
obligatoirement maigre dans la culture
européenne et l'embonpoint et donc
quelqu un cas plutôt des formes
si vous prenez les canons de beauté une
belle femme au xviie siècle est une
femme grâce c'est une femme qui a un
double menton
c'est une femme qui a de la poitrine qui
a du ventre qui a des hanches et vous
avez même des régimes pour prendre du
poids avec des masses pain avec du sucre
alors c'est une société également pour
les élites
on va consommer beaucoup de beurre le
beurre s'impose dans la cuisine
aristocratique au 16e 17e donc on a une
cuisine qui est beaucoup plus onctueuse
mais également beaucoup plus gras c'est
qu'à des conséquences sur la silhouette
féminine mais c'est un élément qui va
être mis en avant comme vraiment un
grand critère de beauté
si vous prenez madame de montespan qui
est l' une des maîtresses de louis xiv
et vous prenez les portraits que nous
avons d'elles on voit qu'elle a un
visage plein qu'elle a des joues qu'elle
un double menton et on a des lettres de
man de madame de maintenon qui
explique qu'elle a croisés madame de
montespan et que l a encore embelli
parce que elle a engraissé à la
engraisser donc à la embellie et c'est
un complément si vous rencontrez une
femme du xviie siècle
si vous le dites que hal a pris du poids
c'est un compliment en revanche le
surpoids et l'obésité est quand même
condamné c'est à dire que dès le
l'époque moderne de l'ancien régime la
grosseur mais du côté de l'obésité
renvoie à une à des gens qui sont
balourd 1 le terme balourd et négatifs
ça renvoie à des gens qui ne sont pas
vif ni de corps ni l'esprit est une
femme qui serait trop grasse risque
d'être stérile quand même il ya cette
idée dans le discours médical donc
l'embonpoint c'est vraiment un juste
milieu mais plutôt gras est à replacer
dans une société qui est une société de
pénurie une société de pénurie ou pour
l'immense majorité de la population
l'objectif c'est quand même de manger à
sa faim et alors passons à la soie la
cuisine mais la cuisine le lieu la
cuisine d'abord depuis qu est ce que la
cuisine est et le centre de la vie
familiale et d'ailleurs les tells encore
je me demande pas ce que l'arrivée des
cuisines américaine dans des
appartements en français par exemple ont
tendance à déplacer le centre david ans
dans le salon enquête qui fait office
également de salle à manger mais le
centre la cuisine en tant que centre de
la vie familiale ces deux corps à caen
en fait je réponds au début de votre
question en fait sur le parallèle avec
les cuisines ouvertes
en fait c'est une façon de remettre la
cuisine dans la vie familiale me semble
comme laïc on revient vers des pièces à
vivre mais avec une ouverture avec le
salon alors que dans la culture
bourgeoise du xixème siècle
la cuisine c'est le lieu des domestiques
ce serait totalement une erreur sociale
que d'aller prendre ses repas en cuisine
si on appartient aux élites et
dans les modèles d'habitat des années 50
on a bien séparer la cuisine de la salle
à manger est donc là on a bien cette
idée de mettre sur le devant de la scène
plutôt la salle à manger
mais dans le temps long de l'histoire
pour l'immense majorité de la population
est donc là je parle pas des élites
en fait on est dedans 1 une manière de
vivre qui est la pièce à vivre qu'est la
pièce unique où on a le lieu où cuisine
le lieu on vit le lieu également où on
dort et ce n'est que chez les élites
qu'on peut se permettre de séparer le
lieu de préparation des repas du lieu où
on va prendre les repas mais ça c'est
vraiment que chez les personnes qui ont
les moyens de se le permettre et qui
vont montrer leurs distinctions sociales
par cette distance qui est une distance
à la fois spatiale est également
culturel c'est à dire que il ya une
sorte de d'élargissement culturel de
d'une cuisine qui est un lieu qui est
plutôt mal vu un lieu en fumée un lieu
bruyant un lieu où il ya des odeurs qui
parfois ne peut pas qu'ils sont pas
forcément apprécié par les élites et le
lieu où on va prendre les repas et une
procession des plats entre le lieu où on
les prépare et le lieu où on va les
manger
et donc ces lieux où on va prendre les
repas ça peut être une salle à manger
si vous prenez le monde romain on a des
systèmes de salle à manger pour les
élites on a des salles de banquets
également pour l'époque médiévale pour
les élites et la salle à manger tel que
on la conçoit dans la culture bourgeoise
c'est un lieu qui va s'imposer
réellement au xviiie siècle dans le
cadre du siècle des lumières et dans le
cadre d'une privatisation de l'espace et
dans une humble mouvement qui est marqué
par un repli sur soi sur la vie
familiale et c'est vraiment au cours du
xviiie que l'on va avoir des espaces
spécifiques qu'on va appeler salle à
manger en occident pour la prise des
repas et
et c'est salle à manger sont vraiment
séparé de la cuisine souvent la salle à
manger est au premier étage qu'elle
étages nobles et la cuisine est plutôt
en sous-sol ou mini enterré ce qui
permet d'avoir cette séparation est ce
qui permet de s'éloigner de l'image
négative que peut avoir la cuisine mais
ça a une conséquence pour les convives
les mangeurs c'est la difficulté de
manger chaud pour les élites qui est un
véritable luxe puisque vous avez le
déplacement entre le lieu où on mange et
le lieu où sont préparés les plats d'où
le système de cloche par exemple sur les
plats pour essayer de garder la chaleur
d'où le système de réchauds sur table
pour conserver des plats un petit peu
tiède et cela explique également que
dans leurs pas dit à la française on
commence par consommer le potage parce
que on veut essayer de le consommer si
ce n'est choquant moins tiède et la
grande révolution pour les élites des
boissons exotiques le thé le café et le
chocolat c'est que elles vont consommer
une boisson chaude frères brûlante et
les élites étaient absolument pas
habitué à cela contrairement à ce qu'on
peut avoir dans les mondes dans le monde
paysan par exemple puisque dans le monde
paysan
on est dans la pièce à vivre il ya une
très très forte proximité entre la
préparation et le lieu où on consomme ce
qui veut dire que dans le milieu paysan
peut consommer des soupes très chaude en
réalité quand on mange directement dans
le chaudron ou à cuila la soupe est donc
ce n'est pas le même rapport évidemment
mais cette proximité pour les élites à
les rapprocher à l'animalité pour les
élites sont les animaux qui sont très
très proches de leur alimentation
alors que pour les élites on va essayer
d'éloigner au maximum et c'est une façon
de montrer leurs distinctions et leur
supériorité sociale et et avoir la
cuisinière alors la cuisinière à gaz la
cuisinière électrique avant la
cuisinière on faisait comme en cd qu'est
ce qu'il y avait dans la cuisine comment
est ce qu'on faisait réchauffer les
plats alors
et par ses lattes le départ c'est le feu
l'atr et le chaudron c'est vraiment ça
dans les premières cuisine ce que l'on
peut avoir est la cheminée pour l'époque
médiévale et l'époque moderne
c'est un endroit où on va avoir trois
plans d'eau de cuisson on a le chaudron
suspendu à la crémaillère et on est
encore une expression française pendre
la crémaillère qui renvoie bien l idée
qu appartement où on a pendu la
crémaillère le foyer existe puisqu'on
peut se nourrir
donc on retrouve bien l'importance de la
nourriture dans la constitution d'un
foyer d'une famille donc ça c'est le
premier plan de cuisson la crémaillère
vous avez un deuxième plan de cuisson
qui est le gris et qui permet donc de
griller des viandes ou de mettre une
poêle à frire sur sur la grille et vous
avez la rôtisserie donc ça c'est les 3
premier plan depuis son que vous avez
avec la cheminée et que l'on a pour
l'époque médiévale et qu'on peut encore
avoir aujourd'hui et la grande
innovation technique dans le monde des
cuisines
ce sera à la renaissance le potager
alors le potager c'est l'ancêtre de la
gazinière ou le fourneau dans les
restaurant le potager c'est un meuble en
maçonnerie à hauteur d' appui sur ce
meuble nous avons va sceller plusieurs
réchaud et c'est réchaud permettent
d'avoir des feux d'intensités
différentes et pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité on peut
sur un même plan de cuisson avoir
différentes cuissons
c'est à dire qu'on peut offrir on peut
réserver on peut faire bouillir et le
potager est également une innovation
intéressante pour le métier de cuisinier
parce que le cuisinier va se redresser
lorsqu'ils cuisinent avec le potager
alors que la cheminée est inconfortable
la cheminée faut se baisser la cheminée
il ya le problème de la présence du feu
le potager c'est pas le cas on se
redresse et donc c'est valorisant pour
le cuisinier et potager est associé à
une fenêtre fenêtre que l'on peut ouvrir
pour évacuer l'oxydé de carbone ce qui
veut dire qu'on fait entrer du jour dans
les cuisines et que l'on peut voir à
l'intérieur des casseroles et les
casseroles sont vraiment liées au
développement du potager et le potager
après ba va donner la la gazinière
ouh la la plaque électrique tels que
nous pouvons la voir aujourd'hui et le
potager donc au départ est en pierre au
18e
on a des potagers portatif en foot et au
19e siècle potager sera un signe de
distinction
un signe de bourgeoisie dans la cuisine
bourgeoise il faut un potager et du
temps de l'empiré colonial français
les colons vont venir avec cette culture
du potager et encore aujourd'hui au
maghred vous pouvez avoir l'expression
potager qui est utilisé pour évoquer la
gazinière ou là la plaque électrique qui
est un héritage de la colonisation ce
qu'on peut comprendre puisque dans les
cuisines vous aviez des domestiques qui
venait de la population maghrébine
autre invention révolutionnaire c'est le
réfrigérateur
on n'imagine pas comment c'était avant
le réfrigérateur le alors juste avant
les années 30 par exemple dans la
majorité grande majorité des familles
françaises
on n'a pas de réfrigérateur comment on
fait alors on fait comme nos ancêtres
comme on l'a fait pendant très très
longtemps
en réalité l'humanité a toujours tenté
d'essayer d'avoir des réserves
alimentaires ses réserves alimentaires
c'est une question de survie bien
pendant très très longtemps ça a été une
question de survie
d'où la valorisation des légumes secs
d'où la valorisation d'un pain qu'on
peut manger rassir trempé par par la
soupe c'est pas encore le règne de la
baguette que l'on doit manger dans dans
la journée voire dans la demi journée
parce qu'après la baguette est
immangeable
là on est sur du pain qui est d'un pain
rassis et également toute une culture
des conserves mai
concert au sens de ce qui permet de
conserver le plus longtemps les aliments
donc c'est très large dans la catégorie
conserve pour l'époque moderne et l
ancien régime
c'est tout ce qui permet donc de les
conserver par exemple visage du sel dans
le beurre c'est une façon de conserver
le beurre le plus longtemps possible
et évidemment que dans les populations
plus anciennes on consomme également le
beurre rance un beurre que nous on
aurait beaucoup de mal à manger
aujourd'hui le sel va permettre
également de conserver les fromages plus
longtemps pensé au parmesan inquiète une
manière de conserver le lait est plus
longtemps également avec le sel on va
également utiliser la fumaison pour
conserver des poissons pour conserver
des viandes on va utiliser le sel pour
conserver le poisson comme le hareng
comme la morue et qui seront des
poissons très prisée au moment du carême
ou pour l'immense majorité de la
population donc c'est le poisson de
conserve qui est consommé vous avez
toutes les conserves de légumes et les
confitures les confitures qui se
développe notamment à partir du xviie
siècle quand on a une augmentation de la
production de sucre de canne aux
antilles là on commence à avoir
développé en occident des conserves de
fruits dont qui prennent le sens de
confiture au sens actuel du terme donc
ils vont jouer également un rôle
important
vous avez une innovation technique fin
xviiie début 19e qui va être capital
parce que ça va permettre le
développement de l'industrie des
conserves telle que nous l'entendons
aujourd'hui c'est la découverte de
nicolas appert qui en fait tu découvres
la stérilisation avant pasteur s'est pas
pasteur qui a trouvé la pasteurisation
c'est quelque chose qu'on connaissait
avant et affaire a compris comment on
pouvait conserver les légumes en les
mettant dans un bocal et en mettant en
stérilisant le bocal dans de l'eau
chaude et donc ça permet de conserver
longtemps
pensez également à toutes les
charcuteries qui sont des charcuteries
de garde donc tous ces éléments fait que
la population à trous
v des moyens de répondre au problème de
la conservation
mais c'est manière de conserver son des
manières qui transforme le goût c'est
que si on fait une histoire du goût des
sensibilités gustatives la conserve
pendant très longtemps a été marqué par
l'agent qu'on utilise pour conserver
l'aliment le sel il faut imaginer que
les skis ancien consomment beaucoup de
scènes accès vital dans leurs économies
le goût également du vinaigre 1 pour ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des pickles ce
n'est qu'ils étaient beaucoup plus
répandue y compris hors du monde anglo
saxon pour conserver des aliments donc
il y avait ce goût également l'acidité
du vinaigre là
la grande innovation de du réfrigérateur
et de la congélation
c'est la possibilité de garder des
fruits des légumes dans leur naturel
dans leur goût naturel ce qui était
impossible avant et quand on prend des
traités de confiture au 17e on nous
explique très bien que les confitures
ont le mérite de conserver son fruit en
son naturel or évidemment que ça change
le groupe il ya le sucre qui est très
présent mais eux disent à conserver le
fruit ans naturel parce que ça permet en
plein mois de décembre d'avoir des
fraises d'avoir des abricots d'avoir des
pêches est la seule manière de pouvoir
les avoir au 17e 18e ou 19e
c'est par les concernent par les
concerts avec le sucré ou l'autre vie
etc
l'anc est lié moi je me disais dans les
années 30 au fond avant le réfrigérateur
on devait faire ses courses tous les
jours et et en plus il n'y avait pas de
supermarché
d'ailleurs on n'aurait rien eu à faire
d'un supermarché puisqu'on ne pouvait
pas conserver les aliments ton qu'au
fond c'est une civilisation qui fait ses
courses au jour le jour
alors ça dépend si vous êtes dans le
monde rural où le monde urbain
il ya la question de l'offre vous avez
entièrement raison
pour les années 30 dans les villes il ya
cette obligation d'aller
acheter les produits frères puisqu'on ne
peut pas stocker chez soi et ça entraîne
de nouvelles consommations en fait les
épiceries vont habitués la population à
ne plus être dans la logique de faire
des réserves puisque dans les épiceries
que l'on trouve en ville on peut acheter
des petites quantités on n'est pas dans
la logique de la boîte d'un kilo de
pâtes ou est ce qu'on peut trouver
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment au jour le
jour
ces éléments qu'on peut trouver encore
aujourd'hui dans certains pays
méditerranéens si vous allez en espagne
par exemple vous pouvez aller chercher
une poignée de légumes surgelés par
exemple c'est sur les marchés c'est des
éléments qu'on peut encore retrouvé et
dernière toute dernière question
l'industrie alimentaire elle né au 19e
siècle avec la farine avec l'huile avec
le sucre puis les confitures vous l'avez
dit les pâtes les conserves
puis les marques apparaissent le
marketing
mais pour ça il faut qu'ils aient des
trains pour acheminer les marchandises
fauqué des télégraphes pour qu'on puisse
pour qu'on puisse les commandes et ses
marchandises et et à partir de ce moment
là on pourra manger la même chose au
nord et au sud la même marque
puisqu'elle sera partout distribués au
fond sans les transports notre
alimentation n'aurait pas changé comme
elle a changé au 20e siècle a totalement
et entièrement raison le 20e siècle le
développement des transports a
obligatoirement modifier nos habitudes
alimentaires et a même eu comme effet
négatif pour l'environnement
au 20ème siècle de nous faire oublier
qu'il y avait des saisons par exemple
penser aux primeurs qui dans la seconde
moitié du 20e siècle viennent de l'autre
bout de la planète et qui ont fait
oublier à des consommateurs que
l'alimentation
elle est aussi marquée par des des
saisons est un des éléments que l'on
voit apparaître aujourd'hui qui est une
alimentation qui renvoie un militantisme
pour mieux vivre la planète ce sont les
circuits courts qui est vraiment un
élément essentiel aujourd'hui dans les
pays occidentaux qui a été d'ailleurs
qu'on
porté par la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons actuellement avec cette
volonté d'avoir vraiment une prise sur
notre alimentation de manger de saison
et de privilégier les productions
locales les maraîchers et donc là il ya
vraiment eu une évolution très
intéressante sur le rapport à la
consommation par rapport à ce qu'on a pu
vivre au 19ème 20ème siècle merci
florent quellier merci d'avoir toute
cette émission avec nous histoire de
l'alimentation de la préhistoire à nos
jours
ça vient de paraître chez belin merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]